ههه
صرخاتهن صوت للالم الم لفقدان اثني عشر
شخصا قتلتهم تركيا في غارات جويه على
الاكراد ليله السبت المنصرم
الذي تسيطر عليه قصد وقصف مدفعي يا
طالبهم وذويهم مدنيون وعسكريون وصحفيون
قتل في الضربات التركيه الاخيره
ماذا فعلنا لهم لمنهاجمهم ولم نسرق
اموالهم لماذا يهاجموننا نحن على ارضنا
وفي وطننا لذلك لا نعرف اي تفسير لصمت
الدول الكبرى
[موسيقى]
تخطن شعبي
في الوقت المناسب وربما تكون العمليتان
العسكريتان في كل تركيا
كردستانهم الموعوده وعمليات التركيه
المستمره لاجهاضه تبقى هذه البقعه من
الارض ساحه مفتوحه للقتل والقتال مع غياب
اي افقر لحلول سياسيه او عسكريه تنهي هذا
الصراع من مدينه ديرك شمال شرق سوريا
جماعه العربيه